we already know now Mia that there's a
lot of companies out there who are
terrible when it comes to cybersecurity
yeah and it's not just terrible when it
comes to cybersecurity it's also when it
comes to you know crisis management I
was working the phones yesterday for the
bulk of my afternoon speaking to experts
in consistently they said Mia there are
more than three lessons because for the
sake of me concise I've come up with
three lessons they said there are
hundreds of lessons that corporations
Sony's peers can learn from this entire
debacle the first is probably identify
your crown jewels now I spoke to Adam
Epstein he's a corporate governance
expert at third Creek Advisors and he
essentially told me that it's amazing
how many of these top companies don't
know what their most important aspects
of their company are what their ideas
are what their IP are and in this case
Sony's case it's this it's the scripts
it's the passwords it's the employee
insurance plans all that information
shouldn't have just not just been known
but it should have been put in a place
that thief's can't find both from a
physical point of view and also from a
digital point of view and the location
of where these this information is at
should also be constantly changing it
shouldn't just be the same place the
second lesson
Betty is threat awareness you were
talking about this earlier you should
monitor alarms it's not just important
to know and have the top-end system you
need to understand how you can turn on
that system that's according to Alan
Freeman he's a cyber security expert at
the George Washington Institute and the
third one Betty is the post breach plan
you know Sony knew that they were going
to upset the North Korean government
they should have anticipated North
Korea's response perhaps North Korea
would have taken a diplomatic approach
and said to them you know we don't want
this movie to be shown or they could
have taken the hacking approach again
they should have planned for all of this
and had all of their statements lawyered
up and they should have had their
responses already put together before
this